l tutti ragazzi per questo video sono
pari j sospettando step che mi venga a
prendere in questo bellissimo gioco
marino ricatto chiami ha lasciato in
mezzo al deserto perché io ho scoperto
di non avere la macchina ha dato che
aspetta aspetta il primato sei lì io
sono qua no perché ragazzi io mi sono
sposato dall'altra parte del mondo è
fatto per prendere la macchina ma non ho
la macchina di gta e proprio come la
vita reale io non ho la macchina
fantastico arrivando dove sta arrivando
del 6 con il cielo si può informarti
city fermati 26 mag e veloce ciao
ma cos'è aspetta che perché già detto
spariamo runner cosa mai sparato era un
ma era un fuoco d'artificio per questo è
bello come si sale alla regale ecco io
so già che il mio dio che aiuto
vissi non guidati ma come funziona ma
aveva portato per sbaglio davvero è sì
però aspetta che a terra
ok niente sono morti oggi ragazzi
dovremo fare un episodio che avevamo già
fatto sul canale youtube players però
non volevo provare a farlo anche sul mio
cioè provare a fare cose legali su gta
già sono ricercate non ho fatto niente
quindi figuriamoci sta già iniziando già
iniziando male siamo partiti malissimo
però è niente quindi proviamo a fare
questa roba qua io farei esattamente
come l'ultima volta quindi se riuscite a
suonare qualche kobe se voi siete
esperti di questa roba qua
esattamente come aveva fatto l'altra
volta facciamo un ritorno proprio ok
ragazzi
proviamo io se come già illegale girare
come stai girando però vabbè proviamo a
fare cose legali allora ecco rischiano
di devi però buttare col rosso fi non
stavano anche guardando mi scusi prego
ti prego parti vere
mi fate fare passate allora vieni come
tu come fai a cambiare vestito così come
scusa è una mia specialità
allora questo veicolo è adatto a
kathmandu questo è il mio esame della
patente va bene salga salga
ecco non ho mai provato neanche devo
provare sbaglio è particolarmente
aspetta che la cosa non lo fa
ma spara come aveva partiamo da da un
momento in cui ciò che da adesso
possiamo fare le cose
il segreto è non premere tasti non
preveniente tra nella varia da fra
davvero che ok
partiamo partiamo per e tu mi fai da
supervisore è sì allora prima cosa è
riuscire a fare almeno dieci minuti di
video da stampare niente di illegale non
c'è scritto che non puoi saltare con la
macchina io sono qui che si è iscritto
spingere la pesante con la macchina non
c'è scrive verde verde verde verde
quindi va bene ok e verde
allora io ho deciso puoi alzare la mano
d'aiuto 9 e il passeggero mio che ha
problemi non solo io che già lo posso
ancora andare avanti perfetto ragazzi
dove tutto a posto tutto giusto rena
brera è giusto perché questa linea
all'incrocio non tornare indietro
questa linea diventa cosa serve a far
passare quando non lo sono gli americani
sono strani australia beh non lo sapevo
anche perché perché il semaforo e dopo
lo vedi che gli infonde infatti è fra
missiva affrancata capisce e poi è
passato guardando a vendere era vero
adesso devo fare le pulci agli altri
tutti i rossi sistema prima basta era
verde sono andato avanti e giallo posso
passare sta facendo anche lui anche lui
guarda guarda lo guardano con le facce
di tutti ora volanti con favore rosso
col rosso è pazzo pazzo è colpa sua io
penso che le batte infatti dire tu però
abbiamo la polizia sia miscuglio guarda
guarda queste città aspetta c'è ma anche
quando provo a fare le cose giuste ma
non ho capito a capo un semaforo
l'hack scusa mimì segue la un incidente
è passato tre volte col rosso assaltato
con l'auto cercando di centrare un caso
richiede del settore un curarla lo
ricordiamo che seguono gli sparano io
sono passato col rosso vi sparano in
faccia ma scusami cosa ho fatto da
limare ma cosa vuoi malamente dai siamo
partiti male ma non ne potevo non poteva
farci gola la facciamo ancora due metri
con questa e poi suggerirei di cambiare
ma questo è scemo ma guarda non so se
lui e lui era verde sono girato ed
aperte guarda lo guarda guarda guarda
che non ci penso io cerco si allarghi in
questi casi di cosa ti fanno arrabbiare
è semplice ma roba che non è proprio in
verde madonna magari bene ma cos'è per
te bellissima come star perfetto ovvero
straw nauta tecnicamente dovresti
rispettare le leggi anche ora che adesso
avendo neanche adesso
mentre andiamo al prossimo step che
tutto il video stein ho capito ma non lo
so che non mi viene addosso
marciapiede ma vabbè come vi serve alla
3a canistrà alla coda ti aspetti come
veicolo una moto strana ma non è poi una
moto quel non è una moto e non ci passa
di qua con la macchina maledizione spera
scendiamo eroe sarà prevenire hanno
parcheggiato nel campo di atletica
perché non è che poi parcheggiare le
altre patrie aeroporto scusami ora non
avesse lunga amico mio non lo so ecco
questo non ho la patente grandi che per
l'altro ha palesato però vabbè vieni
fair e ci sono tutti ci siamo allora
abbiamo dio perché non è vero fa 5 non
so come si faccia realtà è bellissimo
non dovrebbe essere mi piaceva nel mondo
credo di sì non lo so anche io dubbio
però penso di sì ma sfruttiamo che il
suo veicolo penn e dall'altra parte
ancora più a destra proprio retromarcia
verso destra perfetto con questo non
puoi frangere le leggi 1 st giganti
subito scusato così fra gli elementi che
era quella in cielo non c'è nessuno a
meno che numeri che sono i campioni che
riesco a butta giu un aereo te lo dico
io è un pò lontano ma almeno facciamo
poi mio marito divide infrangere le
leggi e grazie lo voglio vedere
all'unico modulo era farmi guidare una
supposta volante gigante migratori
perché noi ce la fa la gara va in quello
dopo aspetta aspetta per troppo avanti
per mandare armatore trovato retromarcia
secondo me non siamo proprio ingegneri
aspetta perché poi non va storto si è
buona e buona buona o no no no no vetro
marzo dentro marcia perfetto incredibile
però me li riguardava dai lago me ma non
ce li farò mai nella vita
mamma mia ragazzi pensavano che dalla
riva vede sta roba
tutto normale la mia tutto a posto
arriva un'onda abbiamo fatto otto
milioni di euro di danni ma fatte
rituffarmi ma non ci è dato per due
pazienti
ma com'è possibile visto speriamo plati
e mara che i peli del petto
ma perché esatto mi sta facendo perché
non lo so ma guardare e vedere per far
per favore di bile e cosa vuoi non so me
li sono fatti che duri farmeli anche il
real però non c'è quindi va bene neanche
io non prendere meglio vorrebbe va bene
tutto ma cosa vuoi che ci hanno i
tatuaggi che sono successe cose brutte
nella vita di questo personaggio era una
macchina da guerra è un sottomarino e un
sottomarino è certo mancava solo questo
è abbronzato l'acido pensili di faccia
andare sott'acqua è proprio per noi è
sott'acqua intima ma ora che riesco a
fare lo stesso vedi in prima persona è
bellissimo è vedi fondali attento a non
investire i pesci e quello è illegale
comincia così il legale che posso fare
qualcosa di sé e sé non c'è nient'altro
allora ci sono un po di pesci c'erano un
po di pesci come esempio che ci sono più
ok avete fatto più può andare veramente
sotto sotto sotto per il figo sicura
visionando la profondità critica lo
svolgerà che fai esplodere tutto al 100
politica della carena come lo sono morto
abbiamo mai giocato prima gara andrea di
normale toccato un euro sto coso grazie
ma era orribile mi è rimasta la maschera
però questa carità bene non fa niente e
tanta rapidità sorta grande con la
campagna tatum a tutti devo in totale
per quello lo zeppelin
allora eravamo un milione e mezzo e 400
dollari
aggiungiamo altri 600 dollari non
sembrava di grande valore perché
minamoto in acqua che stavo arrivando
veloce banda e niente va bene
ragazzi io direi che possiamo conclude
all'acqua perché provare a fare cose
legali suo gioco non fa tanto per me
però c'è un tipo che fa cose strane di
famiglia brindando con una tavola da
surf non stava scattando una foto ma va
a cagà come era un server
perché
ma se ti fai si va dai massi ma non si
fa anche così dai ma ha fatto bene e mi
sono vestito per stare in spiaggia per
cento sulla tabella che tragedie in
attivo nella sala cos'era era il caso
sono la mister sa che fa saltare è stato
va bene allora raga io concludere il
quale episodio ringrazio sempre per
avere partecipato a parte di fitch
la mia proposta ce l'ha fatta
va bene è stato molto difficile ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi
anche alla locale in svizzera come
sempre ci vediamo a bari
[Musica]